where are you on the
spectrum of hope
for
uh the role of automation in trucking
i i think automation is is inevitable
and again i think the this is really
going to be transformative
and it's going to be
i i've studied the history of trucking
technology as much as i can there you
know there's not a lot a lot of great
stuff written and you kind of have to
you know uh there isn't a lot of data
and places to knows or volumes of stuff
and how they're changing etc but
the big
revolutionary changes in in trucking are
because of constellations of factors
it's it's not just one thing right so
daimler builds you know a motorized
truck and i think it's 1896.
right um
inter-city's trucking
that so basically what they use that
truck for is just to swap out horses
right
they basically do the same thing the
service doesn't really change you know
um and then world war one really spurs
the development of bigger larger trucks
like spreads you know air air filled
tires
and then
we start paving roads right and
paved roads right air-filled tires
and the internal combustion engine
now you got a winning mix now it met
with demand for people who wanted to get
out from under the thumb of the
railroads
right so there was all of this pent-up
demand to get cheaper freight from the
countryside into cities and between
cities
that typically had to go by rail
and so now you know
40 years after that internal combustion
engine
it becomes this absolutely essential
right this necessary but not sufficient
piece of technology to create the modern
trucking industry
in the 1930s and i think self-driving is
going to be self-driving trucks are
going to be part of that and the idea i
don't i guess we we credit jeff bezos
the idea is
you know um
okay so sam walton if we can do it like
a slight tangent on sort of the
importance of trucking to business
strategy and sort of how it has
transformed our our world
the central insight that sam walton had
that made him the giant that he was in
influencing the way that so many people
get stuff
was a trucking insight
and so if you look at the way that
he developed his system you build a
distribution center
and then you ring it with stores
those stores are never further out from
that distribution center than a
human-driven truck
can drive back and forth in one day
and so rather than the way all of his
competitors were doing it with
sending trucks all over the place and
having people sleep overnight and sort
of making the trucking service fit
where they had stores
he designed the layout of the stores
right to fit what trucks could do
and so transportation and logistics
right become
walmart's you know edge right and allows
them to to dominate the space that's the
challenge that amazon has
now they've they've mastered the digital
part of it right and now they got to
figure out like how do we you know
dominate the actual physical movement
that complements
that
others are obviously going to follow
but the capabilities of these trucks is
completely different
than
the capability of a human-driven truck
so
if you're smith packing right and you've
got you know uh a bunch of meat in a
warehouse and it's going to grocery
distribution centers
you know you have that trucker probably
come in the night before
and you make him wait so that he has you
know a full 10-hour break which is what
the law requires so that he can get to
the furthest reaches that he can of one
of those stores
right so he can drive his full 11 hours
and and bring that meat so it doesn't
have to sit overnight in that
refrigerated trailer right and so their
system is based on that now what happens
when that truck can now travel
two
times as far right three times as far
now you don't need the warehouses where
they were
now you can go super lean with your
inventory instead of having meet here
meet there meet there you can put it all
right here and if it's cheap enough
substitute those transportation costs
for all that warehousing costs right so
this is going to remake landscapes in
the same way
that big box supply chains did right and
then of course the further complement of
that is
you know how do you then get it to
two people at their door
right and you know the big box supply
chain it moves
very few items in really large
quantities to very few locations
pretty slowly
right
um
ecommerce aspires you know to do
something completely different right
move huge varieties of things in small
quantities virtually everywhere as fast
as possible right um and so that is
like that inter-city
trucking under the you know in the um
era of of railroad monopolies right the
demand for that is potentially enormous
right and and that so there's there's
such a so right now i think a lot of the
the business plans for sort of automated
trucks right and sort of the way that
the journalistic accounts portray it is
like okay if we swap out a human for a
computer what are the labor costs per
mile and like oh here's the
profitability of self-driving trucks
like this is transformative technology
we're going to change the way we get
stuff so we could actually get a lot
more trucks period with like with
autonomous trucks because they would
enable if a very different kind of
transportation networks you think yeah
here's and this is where it's like
oh like
yeah so
wait we really thought we were gonna be
electrifying trucks
if they're going twice as far if they're
moving three times as much if they're
going three times as far right what does
that mean for how far we are behind on
batteries right we've got sort of these
you know ideas about like man we you
know here's how far how close we could
get to meet this demand that demand is
going to radically change right these
trucks are you know so then we've got to
think about all right if it's not
battery you know how how are we powering
these things and how many of them are
they're going to be
like right now we've got 5 million
containers that move from la and long
beach to chicago
on rail
rail is
three or four times at least
more efficient than trucks in terms of
greenhouse gas emissions
and on that lane it varies a lot
depending on demand but maybe rail has a
20 advantage in cost maybe 25 but it's a
couple days slower
so now you cut the cost of that truck
transportation per mile by 30 percent
now it's cheaper than rail and it gets
the stuff there five days faster than
rail
how many millions of containers are
gonna leave la and long beach on
self-driving trucks and go to chicago
and it might look very much like a train
if
if we go with the platooning solution
uh you have just these rows of like
imagine like rows of like 10 like dozens
of trucks or like hundreds of trucks
like some absurd situation
just going from l.a to chicago
just this train but taking up a highway
i mean uh
this is probably a good place to talk
about various scenarios
but before we get there can i can i just
make one one interesting observation
that i made as a driver um when you're
in a truck you're up higher you know so
you can you can see further and you can
see the traffic patterns
and
um cars move them packs
i'm sure there's academic research on
this right but they move in packs they
kind of bunch up behind a slower car and
then a bunch of them break free and this
is sort of on almost free-flowing
highways they kind of move in packs and
you can kind of see them in the truck
so you know rather than platoons we
might have like hives you know of trucks
right so you have like 20 trucks moving
in some coordinated fashion right and
then maybe the self-driving cars are you
know because people don't like to be
around them or whatever it is right you
might have a pod of you know 20
self-driving cars sort of moving in a
packet behind them you know this is what
if the aliens came down or were just
observing
cars which is one of the uh
sort of prevalent characteristics of
human civilization is there seems to be
these cars like moving around that would
do this kind of analysis of like huh
what's the interesting clustering of
situations here
especially with autonomous vehicles i
like this
you